例えば2月13日-2002月13日の22時51分
誕生日の1時間前にスペロああああやマーサーいただいて
そのさまってください動画見ましたよねさよなら
引っ越すんですかいくら何して使うんじゃねえこれから仲良くなるんじゃないですか俺
がウザかったわけじゃないんですよねそれだったら出てないでも聞こえだったそれだっ
たら全然良かったその前に申します
言うならん
ハーイまだ1つから2月13日23:10です
なんかめっちゃ自身時でつを証明が揺れていますめっちゃキレてます
ってがも今もずっと入れている
旬あなたも揺れてるのタイプを様だいぶ治ってきましたけどものすごい揺れてますね
まだ揺れてる
俺の誕生日は
はい残り5分となりました誕生日直前に大きな地震が来てながらする大混乱したしどう
いうテンションに誕生日を迎えればいいのかわからないんですけども
ひとまず
取りますこれまずむずハイドレート肇社長の27歳あと5分で終わりますやー
もう28すよもうマジで若くないです28
ということで今権局はユーチューバーで
代が一番最初に祝ってくれるのがランディングがー
やっていこうと思いますはい両腕私初の雪を人望が薄いで有名です泣かない
ユーチューバーさんとか結構少なくてですね実は寂しい男なんですというわけで
ちょっとのゲイルが友達は抜いてユーチューバーで大会が一番先に僕を祝ってくれるか
ちょっと検証してみたいと思いますという話をしているともうあと1分ですね
いやもうね
本当はみんなではいえばいい僕の誕生日祝ってほしかったんですけども
こういうご時世でねなかなか人も集まれるずに動く仕事現場東京起きてて今日も夜まで
ちょっとお仕事して明日も朝からまた仕事があるんで
あかかったって話をしてると思うあの0時になりましたスタージョウビ
おめでとうございます
悪鬼とあまず後半伸ばせですねまず強い飲ませ頂きました
かずみさん28歳の誕生日でとーございますそうぞやめろの動画で撮りましょう
投げていったこいつへ2分が経過しましたやばいですね今のところ誰にも行いですああ
なんかはいいんですけどちょっとユーチューバーというわけではないんですねやばいぞ
俺やばいぞか今のままだと誰にも言われるんですまでまとめてやばいや6
ちょっとちょっと待って待って待ってばやばやば
者のか後ろなのかこれジェロあるぞ別に俺はいいんだけど動画的にマジでやばいぞこれ
twitter になれば祝ってくれてないか
[音楽]
それでもですよ2人2人がもう日付変わった瞬間に送っておける時点で俺はね
リア充大事な友達っていうのでも2人ぐらいあればもう十分なんですよ
あちあほすい
う皆さんミスラカーン付呪
3白さ見知らさあの大斬刀流のはた最強の美容師さんなんですけども
8ユーチューバーとなりまして一番なかったです未沙のえるでございまーす
goo
1生産は嬉しいですね待っていますそう僕の誕生日の直前に大きな地震があったので
なかなかね行為バー気分になれないところもあると思うんで
山井は誰も来ないというふうに確認書
13分たちました今のところ三品さんだけでございます
野草をなんすけどちょっ
誰猛虎なすぎてなるほどですね難しいなぁ
そうですねいやそうなんで僕もすげー迷っ
ってるんですよねやばいな企画課たんでなんか終わりそうですもう嫌
活性な
最悪のタイミングですねもうまからちょっと
考えて動いてみますはい多分その方向はやめておきます
入った部署も停電された方が一定数いらしさにそうなればたぶんちょっと嫌な思いされ
そうなんです
はい了解でした始めます拝島線夜中にありがとうございます
はい一礼しますいやー
ずちょっとあの誕生日直前の自身がですね8万件ぐらいすごい停電が起きてるみたいで
そんな中お祝いしてくれるユーチューバーなかなかいないと思うんですよ
a 待ってどう立ち回ったらいいんだろうな何をすれば1ます幸せなんだみんなが
難しいているし
ユーチューバー全然弄ってくれんすトミカ
誕生日おめでとうございましてきましたね0で16分ありがとう
チェーンが本当に難しい
鍛造日になってしまったホンダツイッターでを用意しているユーチューバー参考募集
しようとか思ったんですけども軽減されている場所に住んでいるユーチューバーさんを
いらっしゃるかもしれないして俺の知ってる中で仲良い人でそんな状況でやっぱりお
祝いしてくれっていうのもさすがにおかしいな話なんで
この企画に上げますはやばいなちょっと28さん左すっげー
選択迫られている今はこの企画やるべきじゃないと思うみんながみんなそういう状況
じゃないんですけど一部の人が自身で苦しい状況の中で祝ってくるっていう
おかしいな
やめておきましょういわば28歳やに飯食えんさー肉問われてるよどう発信したら人が
傷つかずに嫌な思いスムーズにするのか
入ってるみなさん無事ですか受信ございますを食べるございますありがとうございます
なんか地域によってはね停電が起きているみたいで余震が続いている
大丈夫ですか北海道無事した大よかったよかったお誕生日はありがとうございます
親父みんなただどうやってライブの日かわかんないんでねとちょっと大きな事件があっ
たということでちょっと企画を止めて眉を廃止にしました
いやーもうこれが今の俺のんできることかなと思いましたね
むずいわもう本当に難しかったなぁただねまつがいなくねこういう大きな事件があった
後はまた
増備であったとしても何かしら人のためになることをすべきかなと思ってライブ配信さ
せていただきました
たくさんお祝いのコメントもいただいたんですけども本当に実施ンって突然来るから
どんな時でも突然包んで本土おちゃらけたリアそんなにはまあバカみたいなことをし
たり多少やんちゃなことをもう全然俺今後していきましたもっとしますしますけど何か
のタイムで地震が来て自分を良く見せるために動画を作ってるわけじゃないんですよ
本当に自分がしたいために動画撮ってるとこがあると思うんですけど本当にでは
インフレレーサーとしてやるべきこととかやってはいけないことはあると思うんでまぁ
28歳人としてもっと成長できるようなんですヨ8000にしようと思います山
難しかった俺ももっとだけ子
じゃあみたいな誕生日のどうしたかったのにそれはすべきじゃないなという
判断で園芸18歳の誕生日でございます
見て朝の仕事も頑張ります本と雑誌にあったとはいつでも出来る準備だけしっかりして
くださいはい28歳肇社長もよろしくお願いますうんなんといいね土居なっちゃった
くそ
あっはっは